So far,
we've seen how to hijack requests and
respond to them differently.
We've even created responses ourselves,
meaning we can respond without
using the network at all.
However, if we want to be able to
load Wittr without using the network,
we need somewhere to store the HTML,
the CSS, the JavaScript, the images,
the web font.
Thankfully, there is such a place,
the cache API.
The cache API gives us this
caches object on the global.
If I want to create or
open a cache, I call caches.open
with the name of the cache.
That returns a promise for
a cache of that name.
If i haven't opened a cache of that name
before, it creates one and returns it.
A cache box contains request and
response pairs from any secure origin.
We can use it to store fonts,
scripts, images, and anything,
really, from both our own origin
as well as elsewhere on the web.
I can add cache items using cache.put
and pass in a request or a URL and
a response.
Or I can use cache.addAll.
This takes an array of requests or
URLs, fetches them, and puts the
request-response pairs into the cache.
This operation's atomic.
If any of these fail to cache,
none of them are added.
addAll uses fetch under the hood, so
bear in mind that requests
will go via the browser cache.
Later, when we want to get something out
of the cache, we can call cache.match,
passing in a request or a URL.
This will return a promise for
a matching response if one is found, or
null otherwise.
caches.match does the same, but
it tries to find a match in any cache,
starting with the oldest.
So we have somewhere to store our stuff,
but when should we store it?
Thankfully, there's another service
worker event that helps here.
When a browser runs a service worker for
the first time,
an event is fired within it,
the install event.
The browser won't let this new service
worker take control of pages until its
install phase is completed, and
we're in control of what that involves.
We use it as an opportunity to get
everything we need from the network and
create a cache for them.
So let's do that for Wittr.
Over in the service worker file,
I'm going to add a listener for
the install event.
Event.waitUntil let's us signal
the progress of the install.
We pass it a promise.
If and when the promise resolves, the
browser knows the install is complete.
If the promise rejects,
it knows the install failed, and
this service worker should be discarded.